- Another gym day with Jordan.
- 'Sup guys?
- That's it.
Not gonna be the
greatest DailyVee ever.
("Monday To Monday"
by Saba)
Saba mother fuckers.
I've been telling you.
This fucking workout
is pissing me off.
That's when you know it's good.
When it pisses
you off, it's good.
What's going on on this Sunday?
A lot going on.
Life is good.
AJ just turned 30.
That was good.
Jordan, just grinding long.
Another kind of like
workout and family Sunday.
Nothing too crazy.
Just want to remind everybody
actions louder than words.
Business, life,
parenting, politics,
all of it, it's your actions.
Everybody's getting
lazy with comments.
Think it's enough.
You gotta do.
Doing always wins.
("Mannequins" by Bazanji)
- [Jordan] Four,
three, two, one.
Good.
Nice job.
Sixtys. (laughs)
- [Gary] Jordan and
I were just talking.
About to do some weird push-ups
on this ball but anyway,
I just kind of looked at myself
and I'm happy with the progress
and I just said
seven days a week.
Day in and day out.
Day in and day out seven days a
week and it's so interesting to
me this is the exact episode
of DailyVee to pass on to your
fitness friends so many of them
get it when it comes to being in
the gym but then they think a
couple of shirtless selfies on
Instagram are enough to build
their business and they're not
putting in that seven days
a week day in and day out.
I didn't realize that people
thought it wasn't true and
that's the truth and that's
the truth for so many of you
watching right now.
You didn't think it was true.
You didn't think
it was true that
they were 15, 16 hour a day.
You thought they were
hyperbolized and
that they were eight or nine.
You didn't realize like
every minute was something.
You didn't realize
that it's every day.
Always, forever and
not that this is
for everybody but it
speaks to it surely is
eliminated the luck thing and
what I don't think people
realize is this has been going
on every day for the last
seven years at this pace.
Every day.
Day in and day out work.
That's it.
I mean there's
really just nothing else.
There's your talent,
your strategy and
the work you put in.
Those are three pillars, right?
You've got your talent and
for the 99.9% of us we can
only maximize our talent, right?
Like when I talk about not
having a big enough chest.
Some people just
naturally have that.
Some people can
naturally just sell.
Some people can naturally
just put the ball in the hoop.
There's your talent
and if you put in
the work you can maximize that.
There's the work, which
is the most controllable.
It's the thing
that we all control.
I could've not come in the gym
this Sunday morning or I can.
Like, it's just the work.
You could stay up another
hour and work on your copy.
The work you've put in Jordan on
your social since you come with
me that's just the work.
- Yeah.
- You either do it or you don't.
When I busted your chops about
Instgram first couple days this
year, I said, "Did you do it?"
You're like, "Yeah."
I go, "No you didn't.
You did one photo not three."
Right?
- Right.
- See, it's just the work.
And then the strategy, right?
If you have the wrong strategy,
if you're putting in all your
efforts on Google+
right now, you're wrong.
If you're putting all your
efforts in the gym on stuff that's
not helping you because
you don't have a trained
professional or you
didn't get good advice,
you're not gonna win as much.
Those are the three things
I want everybody to think about.
You got your natural talent,
don't be crippled
by what you can't do.
Worry about what you can do.
You've got your work.
It's the number one thing
I push 'cause it's the
most controllable.
And then you've
got the strategy.
And that's the part that we need
to kind of expand
on here in 2017.
That's why I talk about
day trading attention.
When I was warming
up Jordan was like,
"You think it's just
good to amass attention?"
Is that what you said?
- Eating's the most important
just like getting attention.
- Yeah. It is.
It's like then you
know how to deploy it.
So those are the three pillars.
("Mannequins" by Bazanji)